جماهير ريال مدريد تودع جاريث بيل مطالبون
باستقالته رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي وفاه
فياري تجمع نجوم ايطاليا السابقين هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
في خطوه فاجات عالم الرياضه
لعب كره القدم ليسدل بذلك الستار على
مسيره مميزه حقق فيها مختلف الالقاب
الاوروبيه خاصه مع نادي ريال مدريد جماهير
نادي الاسباني اعادت نشره ابرز اهداف
النجمه من السابق مع الفريق من بينها هدفه
الشهير في نهائي كاس ملك اسبانيا امام
برشلونه واهدافه في نهائي دوري ابطال
اوروبا 2018
نوال لو قريت رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره
القدم ادخل نفسه في حرب كان في غنى عنها
بعد تصريحاته ضد اسطوره المنتخب زين الدين
زيدان وطفت الى السطح قضايا جديده تخص
رئيس الاتحاد من بينها مزاعم منذر التحرش
الجنسي وبعد الشهادات التي بدات بالخروج
من قبل اشخاص متاثرين بها وسيواجهه تحقيقا
من اعضاء اللجنه التنفيذيه للاتحاد
الفرنسي الذين طلبوا اجتماعا واستثنائيا
للاستماع لهم
ريال مدريد وفوره صدور هذه التصريحات سرعه
بنشر بيان رسمي سند من خلاله زيزو لكن بعض
التقارير الاعلاميه اشارت الى امكانيه
اقاله انشلوطي في نهايه الموسم الحالي
والتعاقد مع زيدان لتكون فتره ولايته
الثالثه مع نادي الملكي واشارت صحيفه
سبورت الكتالونيه ان هذا الخيار قد يطرح
ان خرج ريال مدريد
في مدينه كريمونا مسقط راس قطر
النجوم اليوفنتوس السابقين
بالاضافه الى اسطوره انتر ريكاردو فيري
ومن المقرر ان المقامه جنازه جيهان لوكا
خلال الايام المقبله في العاصمه
الانجليزيه لندن